gospel métal ou encore jazz c'est dans
la diversité que la batterie de
guyancourt a fêté la musique avec un peu
d'avancé samedi une quinzaine de groupes
ont animé les quatre mille mètres carrés
du site entièrement dédié à la musique
faut savoir que c'est des groupes locaux
la plupart du temps du territoire qui se
présente à peu près une demi heure entre
une demi heure et 45 minutes et surtout
une diversité
on a aussi bien du classique que de la
chorale que du groupe musiques actuelles
jazz dans leur sélection valeur il est
demandé bien sûr d'avoir cette diversité
amateurs ou semi-professionnels ces
groupes se sont produits sur les
systèmes de la batterie dans une
ambiance chaleureuse malgré le mauvais
temps le tout premier concert on avait
un petit peu d'appréhension pour à peu
près pour tout le monde
comme quand c'est pour la première fois
et ça c'est moi j'ai trouvé ça très très
bien pour cette sixième édition le
public est une nouvelle fois répondu
présent
l'occasion pour la salle de spectacles
de se faire connaître seul moyen
découvrir le site
c'est vrai que la batterie tout le monde
ne connaît pas forcément le site
on fait ça chaque année puis d'autres
villes et bien sûr dès la 30 e + 35
concerts par an ce qui commence à y
avoir des certains habitués mais ça
ramène toujours du grand public et pour
ceux qui n'ont pas pu profiter de la
musique ce week end
séance de rattrapage demain soir à
versailles